tonight the City of Garden Grove  encountered several acts of violence  throughout our community tonight we were  investigating a double stabbing directly  behind me where two victims had been  stabbed repeatedly as our investigators  were handling this scene we began to get  additional reports of several other acts  of violence throughout our community  that involved this suspect  our undercover investigators located the  suspect vehicle in front of the 7-eleven  at Harbor and First Street in the city  of Santa Ana they quickly called for  assistance from the Santa Ana Police  Department as they conducted  surveillance of the vehicle Santa Ana  Police Department arrived quickly and as  they entered the parking lot  the suspect exited the 7-eleven carrying  a handgun and a large knife  the suspect was ordered to comply with  the officers at which time he dropped  both weapons and complied and was taken  into custody without further incident